you do boys boys and hoodies are smashed
yeah damn success yeah at that point
at that point were you bit by the acting
bug yeah because
it went to cannes film festival
like
i haven't been back to cannes film
festival since boys and girls wow so
this is the first movie
it's not even playing in america yet but
we're going to go show it in france and
we want you to come wow so we go and i
get there and i'm like
oh this is a big deal like
kansas is like crazy i didn't know
nothing about it you know what i mean so
in parallel where are you in your music
career at this point
at the height of my solo career like
just dropped america's most wanted
i think uh
either just dropped killer wheel or
about to drop my second ep
you know it was rolling you know i was
working on my third i mean working on
death certificate and so
being there and
we get there
and then i'm like damn when we showing
the movie
he's like we're gonna show it on
thursday whatever we did get there on
monday
and then i started thinking i'm like
these people speak french like how they
gonna understand the movie yeah what's
the translation and they was like
subtitles i'm like oh
they are not gonna understand this movie
so i'm like this [ __ ] about to be
tortured mm-hmm right
we get there it's quincy jones
in the damn audience eddie murphy
biggest of the big yeah you got no idea
you don't know what kansas is you got no
idea i mean this is like
gregory hines and all these dudes in
there like
and
they gave it a standing ovation that the
movie was over wow
and so i was like damn if they love it
here
wait till they play this in the states
it's over
okay now we're talking about cube and
hollywood before i go to
the
the later transition of the want for
more you know
now
you're talking about the idea music
career what's the conversation from
the music side of you you know you got
partners you got friends you got you
know there's other people that are with
you on that music side they're traveling
with you that's a part of that world
what's their reception to what's going
on it was with it you know it was you
know playing doughboy
was
kind of parallel to the music we was
doing so
it didn't feel like it was it just felt
like a natural progression
you know and and then
my next movie after after boys in the
hood was trespass so
playing save on which is another street
dude
it kind of
fell in you know into place but then you
know i was offered
i was offered uh to if i wanted to play
the old dog and minister society out of
here um why did you take it
i i felt like i was playing the same
character you know it was like
from from
from doughboy to save on to old dog
i felt like i was going to be trapped in
this
you know how are you l.a
thinking like that though at that point
like well i just knew about typecasting
at this point the office that is coming
in
they coming in i'm pretty you know
pretty regularly
um but you know i still wanted to do
stuff that was
you know not not
you know just the normal
hood movie mm-hmm um
because there was so many coming out you
know it was like
it was like from colors to
you know boys in the hood to that was
the thing back the minister society the
south centrals like it was a couple that
was the the cup of tea yeah that's what
that's what got the volume that's what
got the eyeballs the attention because
at the time the gang violence etc yeah
you know it was extremely high it was on
the news every day that's why i wrote
friday
i wrote friday because me and pooh was
looking and
we would look at these movies and be
like damn
was it that bad growing up around here
cause it seemed like it's terrible like
war zone was it though i mean sometimes
but we have fun too yeah so i wanted to
show that like
let's show how we looked at this stuff
how we approached it how we
uh cope with it
you know and laughed at things that i
guess would make most people cry
you